[Musique]
la présidente du Front national Marine
Le Pen est l'invitée de preuve par 3
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous après
les élections départementales qui
traduisent un bouleversement politique
avec la forte progression du FN selon le
constat adressé entre autres par Manuel
Vals ça vous fait au moins un point
commun un point d'accord avec le Premier
ministre preuve par trois en association
bien sûr comme chaque semaine avec
l'Agence France Presse représenté ce
soir par Guillaume dadin avec D Mion
également et bien sûr avec per inarna de
Public Sénat au surlendemain de son
échec électoral manuel Val est resté à
Paris ce mardi face au députés plutôt
que d'aller à Berlin où s'est rendu
François Hollande pour un conseil des
ministres franco-allemand le chef de
l'État a confirmé le cap des réformes il
sera maintenu et le Premier ministre
donc devant l'Assemblée nationale marine
le a été très clair pas de changement de
politique mais son amplification en
faveur de l'investissement des
entreprises pas de remanement pas de
démission qu'avez-vous envie de
souhaiter au Premier ministre un an pile
après son arrivée à Matignon alors
d'abord je remarque que le Président de
la République à chaque fois qu'il perd
une élection il file à Berlin pourêre
justifié auprès de Madame Merkel c'est
quand même pas très rassurant ça
confirme ce que nous disons à savoir que
il est en fait un sous-préfet de l'Union
européenne et il va donc chercher ses
ordres ou se faire taper sur les doigts
ou euh exprimer auprès de Madame Merkel
le fait que malgré les résultats des
élections c'est très révélateur he sur
le plan du fonctionnement de la
démocratie malgré les résultats des
élections et bien il continuera la
feuille de route que lui a donné l'Union
européenne et ce de la manière la plus
servile qui soit vous imaginez bien que
moi qui suis attaché à la souveraineté
de la France ceci me dé me déplaît
absolument
profondément rien d'étonnant à ce que
Manuel Vals annonce qu'il va continuer
sur la même voie il l'avait dit avant
même le résultat bon donc donc les
Français ont le sentiment que ce sont
des élections pour rien puisque quoi
qu'ils disent quoi qu'ils expriment par
leur vote et bien le gouvernement
continue de manière rectiligne à envoyer
la France dans le mur puisque c'est la
politique d'austérité nous avions
annoncé au Front national qu'après
Macron 1 il y aurait Macron 2 pu après
il y aura Macron 3 et bien voyez Macron
2 pointe le bout de son nez mais vous ne
souhaitez pas au moins que Manuel Vals
dise vrai quand il dit que la reprise
est là qu'il y a des signes positifs
mais mais écoutez ça fait 2 ans et demi
qu'on nous raconte cette faribol ça va
arrêter et encore je suis gentil parce
que Nicolas Sarkozi nous faisait la même
chose avec Madame Lagarde vous souvenez
pas Madame Lagarde tous les 6 mois elle
arrivé en disant la crise est derrière
nous tous les 6 mois et tous les 6 mois
la crise s'aggravait et elle revenait
imperturbablement pour dire la crise est
derrière nous mais je veux dire pendant
combien d'années ils vont nous prendre
comme ça pour des enfants évidemment que
la la crise est là le chômage est massif
il continue d'augmenter et il n'y a
absolument aucun signe de reprise les
petits fr tim d'ailleurs qui existent ne
sont pas liés à la politique du
gouvernementz-moi la France peut en
profiter non mais d'accord ok très bien
mais ça n'a aucune relation avec la
politique mise en œuvre par le
gouvernement c'est lié c'est lié à la
baisse de de du niveau de l'euro tiens
je remarque la baisse du niveau de
l'euro tout le monde s'en félicite quand
c'est pas Marine Le Pen qui la propose
mais c'est pas grave bon répété
aujourd'hui qu'il l'avait réclamé
également ah d'accord donc quand moi je
demandais une dévaluation c'était
épouvantable ça allait être le chaos
mais quand eux ils demandent une
dévaluation et bien c'est merveilleux ça
apporte des points positifs non mais je
le note bon c'est lié à la politique de
plancheabillet de l'Union européenne
donc je rappelle que quand je la
proposais quand je proposais pour la
France de la création monétaire on
m'expliquait que ça allait être aussi le
chos mais qu' au niveau européen ça ne
cré pas bon sens alors au niveau
européen non non c'est non je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi mais non ça n'est pas
la politique qu'il faut mener car la
réalité c'est que cette planche habillé
elle sert en réalité à renflouer les
banques et non pas à aider les à
relancer l'économie réelle et puis
troisièmement la baisse du pétrole la
baisse du prix du pétrole donc tout cela
n'a strictement rien à voir avec une
action positive de la part du
gouvernement et et par conséquent il n'y
a qu'à hélas s'attendre à une
aggravation de l'austérité qui elle en
revanche continue sur une belle lancée
alors néanmoins donc manuel Vals propose
d'amplifier certaines réformes vous
l'avez entendu il miseent par exemple
sur des plans d'investissement massif
d'ordre privé d'ordre public également
il l'a annoncé mais d'ordreé il n ça ne
dépend pas de lui si vous voulez il fait
les promesses en disant je vous promets
que avec le portefeuille de l'autre je
vais vous donner de l'argent mais ils
n'en savent rien c'est c'est exactement
l'opération qui a été menée par l'Union
européenne en disant nous on va mettre
quelques milliards et vous allez voir le
privé va se précipiter pour investir bah
attendons de voir quand même
permettez-moi de ne pas les croire sur
parole car je suis pas sûr que les
investisseurs privés aujourd'hui ils
aient très envie d'investir massivement
compte tenu du fait que eux ils sont
quand même conscients que précisément la
crise n'est pas fini al il s'agit de les
inciter notamment sur le plan fiscal on
verra le détail des mesures lorsqu'elles
seront exposées Marine Le Pen le Premier
ministre mise aussi sur des embauches
facilité dans les PME qui auraiit alors
la possibilité de licencier plus
facilement que pensez-vous de cette
deuxième piste de recherche en faveur de
l'emploi non mais attendez la la
facilité de licencier les gens ça crée
pas de l'emploi excusez-moi ou alors
faut m'expliquer comment ça marche je
dire le fait de pouvoir licencier plus
facilement ça va créer de l'EMP les
patrons de PME disent que ça nous
permettra d'embaucher plus facilement si
on peut se séparer des salariés en cas
de difficultés économiques c'est leur
discours arrêtez jamais aucune loi n'a
été faite pour les PME ça c'est
l'enrobage du paquet cadeau la réalité
c'est que ces lois-là elles sont faites
pour les grands groupes et qu'est-ce que
ça va être facile pour un grand groupe
de dire ah bah vous voyez ma filière là
elle perd de l'argent alors il faut que
je licencie massivement parce
qu'entre-temps il aura transféré ses
bénéfices dans une autre filière
peut-être même dans un autre pays vous
le savez parfaitement donc ça c'est fait
pour les grands groupes c'est pas fait
pour les PME et encore une fois on gère
la pénurie mais où est-ce qu'on crée de
l'emploi avec ces mesures-là il n'y a
pas de création d'emploi car pour créer
de l'emploi il faut radicalement changer
le modèle économique et il faut tourner
le dos à la politique d'austérité qui va
s'accélérer car c'est l'objectif de la
loi Macron et nous sommes là d'ailleurs
dans cette loi-là dans les annonces de
Monsieur vas exactement comme par hasard
dans ce que réclame l'Union européenne
c'est drôle c'est exactement ce qu'ils
ont réclamé à la Grèce aussi voyez donc
et on voit ce que ça a donné pour la
Grèce car la
situationour on en parlera plus tard
mais on voit surtout l'action du nouveau
pouvoir ah ben voyons ils sont là depuis
3 mois c'est eux qui vont être
responsables de la baisse de 25 % des
salaires c'est eux qui vont être
responsables des 60 % de chômage chez
les jeunes faut quand même être un petit
peu juste et honnête la réalité c'est
que la situation de la Grèce aujourd'hui
est exclusivement de la responsabilité
de l'Union européenne et de la troï qui
ont imposé à ce pays une cur d'austérité
massive qui a arrêté l'économie arrêté
l'économie et précipité le peuple grec
dans une souffrance inoui alors on
reviendra sur la situation de la Grèce
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure dans la
dernière partie de l'émission avec
perarn si vous êtes d'accord un mot
peut-être sur le plan social qui
s'annonce aujourd'hui en tous les cas la
décision de justice la liquidation de du
transporteur mais global avec 2 qu
salariés qui se retrouve sur le sur le
carreau le gouvernement les pouvoirs
publics s'étaient porté au secours de
l'actionnaire qui manifestement là a été
défaillant que feriez-vous vous face à
cette situation je les protégerai de la
concurrence internationale déloyale
c'est ça qui les tue d'accord c'est ça
qui tue les transporteurs c'est la
concurrence internationale déloyale
c'est se retrouver en concurrence avec
des
entreprises qui utilise des comment dire
des conducteurs qui n'ont absolument pas
les mêmes normes sociales qui n'ont
absolument pas les mêmes temps de
travail et évidemment confronté à cela
et bien les entreprises de transport
français ne peuvent pas lutter contre
cette conur par des entreprises
françaises là qui vont embaucher à
l'étranger mais ils ne peuvent pas faire
autrement monsieur car pour être
compétitif on les force à faire cela
c'est exactement comme quand on a mis en
place la directive détachement des
travailleurs quand une entreprise d'un
secteur utilise des travailleurs
détachés les autres entreprises sont
obligés aussi de le faire car sinon et
bien elles sont elles n'ont plus qu'à
fermer boutique donc le gouvernement
avec cette directive détachement des
travailleurs organise une préférence
étrangère à l'emploi puisque le
travailleur étranger coûtant moins cher
c'est lui qui passe en premier et de
surcroix il oblige en quelque sorte les
entreprises qui voudrai faire du
patriotisme économique à précisément
aller embaucher à l'étranger je veux
dire on marche sur la tête quoi manuel
Val se montre constant dans son combat
son combat contre vous vous l'aurez
entendu contre le Front National au nom
il l'a répété devant l'Assemblée
nationale au nom des valeurs de la
République Marie Le Pen et il prévient
et il prévient je continuerai il vous a
donc identifié comme le péril numéro 1
on se demande si ça vous sert finalement
c'est pas le fondamentalisme islamiste
le péril numéro 1 non c'est pas le
terrorisme c'est pas parce que le Front
national lui il a fait de mal à personne
il est ni
responsable il est ni responsable du
terrorisme ni responsable du chômage ni
responsable de l'insécurité ni
responsable de la dette ni du déficit et
cetera et cetera quelle valeur de la
République alors il dit notamment que le
pays est trop divisé trop fracturé
est-ce que vous êtes d'abord quelle
valeur parce que moi je remarque une
chose si vous voulez c'est que je vais
sur des plateaux de télévision où je
vois des journalistes répétés comme des
perroquet que racontent les uns et les
autres et d'Ur c'est toujours la même
chose et les valeurs de la République
les valeurs de la République j'ai pas vu
un journaliste leur poser la question
lesquels lesquels
précisément monsieur Vals dit franç est
enti républicain précisément
pourquoi d'acc personne mais d'accord
mais personne ne lui pose la question ça
ce sont ce sont des paroles verbales
contre les valeurs de la lesquelles moi
je tiens que le Front National est celui
qui précisément non seulement respecte
le plus les valeurs de la République
mais cherche à imposer à la classe
politique le respect des valeurs de en
tout il le dit il va continuer le combat
sur ce thème-là oui mais d'accord mais
parce qu'il a rien d'autre à dire
permettez-moi quand on peut pas défendre
son propre bilan tellement il est
mauvais tellement il est nul
et bien il faut bien essayer de
détourner l'attention alors on détourne
l'attention en luttant la vieille bonne
méthode qu'on connaît depuis des
décennies contre le Front National qui
est accusé de tous les mots qui est paré
de tous les défauts et et et qui encore
une fois est accusé d'être un danger
mais un danger pour qui à part pour eux
à part pour cette classe politique qui a
peur du du Grand remplacement mais du
Grand remplacement de la classe
politique par le Front national d'c vous
parlez pas des immigrés le grand
remplacement non non je je parle du
rempl du Grand remplacement de la classe
politique par le Front national
représentant du peuple français alors
dans les critiques qui visent le Front
national il y a celle du célèbre couple
Serge et béat clarfeld hein le le
célèbre avocat chasseur de nazi qui
annonce d'ailleurs qu'il quittera la
France si vous êtes élu et il vous voit
porter un fascisme à la française alors
que que le je l'ai entendu dire que
l'arrivée au pouvoir de Marine Le Pen
serait la destruction de la mémoire de
la Choa non mais sérieusement non mais
c'est délirant quoi je ve dire c'est
complètement délirant c'est quoi c'est
c'est ça l'axe d'attaque pour les
quelques mois qui vont nous séparer de
la présidentielle c'est mettre une mèche
et une moustache ça va être ça l'axe
d'attaque mais je veux dire c'est c'est
c'est en même temps pitoyable dérisoire
grotesque et et objectivement assez daté
faut dire h par rapport à bah par
rapport à l'histoire de votre parti mais
par rapport à 2002 on a déjà fait ça je
veux dire encore une fois enfin on va
recommencer moi je vous rappelle les
propos de monsieur Jospin après 2002 qui
avait dit mais enfin écoutez il y a
jamais eu de danger fasciste en France
le Front national n'a jamais été un
mouvement fasciste tout ça c'est du
théâtre disait Lionel Jospin voilà
ancien Premier ministre tout ça c'est du
théâtre et bien il Contin continuent
comme des mauvais acteurs
joui oui je parle je parle de lui mais
si je parle d'eux je parle de de l'UMP
je parle du Parti socialiste ce sont des
vieux acteurs qui jouent qui joue et qui
rejoue une pièce de théâtre qui n'a plus
de spectateurs si on reste quelques
secondes encore sur le couple de Serge
et be clarfeld qui ont pour chassé toute
leur vie durant les anciens nazis et qui
publient ces jour-ci leurs mémoire mais
il y a peut-être une incompréhension
mais vous avez envie peut-être
d'exprimer peut-être votre admiration
pour ce qu'ils ont fait dans leur VI
pardon je je je ne va exprimer aucune
admiration pour des gens qui m'accusent
moi hein de vouloir détruire la mémoire
de la Choa mais je suis né en 68 moi
monsieur qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
cinéma je veux dire qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce cinéma alors moi je suis
scandalisé par ce type de déclaration
scandalisé voilà je trouve que c'est
indigne indigne non seulement vis-à-vis
de moi ce qui serait SEM toutoute pas
très grave indigne vis-à-vis des
millions d'électeurs français qui votent
pour le Front national des 25 % des
électeurs français qui votent pour le
front
national on va revenir sur le calendrier
électoral si vous le voulez bien après
les départementales les régionales et
puis bien sûr la présidentiel vous
n'avez pas décroché d'exécutifs dimanche
dernier mais vos élus même en nombre
limité vous donne évidemment plus
d'ancrage territorial c'était l'un de
vos objectifs comme le montre l'enquête
de Marie bremau avant d'accueillir notre
confrère de la FP Guillaume
Daudin aucun doute avec ces élections
départemental le Front national confirme
son implantation locale en phase
ascendante depuis le milieu du qu Kena
Sarkozi il a été capable de présenter
des candidats dans quasiment
l'intégralité des cantons et ensuite
parce que au premier tour il a reçu plus
de 25 % des suffrages alors que la plus
grande partie de ces candidats étaient
nouveaux et inconnus des électeurs et
dans toutes les villes qu'il dirigent le
FN progresse par rapport au premier tour
des élections municipales de 2014 à
Fréjus et au Pontet de ville tombé dans
lesescarcell du Front national il y a un
an les binom F ont même été élus dès le
premier tour et si au final le Front
national remporte que 31 cantons le
parti compte désormais 62 conseillers
départementaux au lieu d'un seul en plus
des 1600 conseillers municipaux et des
118 conseillers régionaux actuels ce
dernier chiffre pourrait bien fortement
grossir lors des futures élections
régionales de décembre prochain avec un
mode de scrutin plus favorable au FN et
on se rend compte qu'à la fois en
npatcal et Picardie et en PACA le Front
national pourrait obtenir jusqu'à 35 %
des suffrages ce qu'il mettra en i de
diriger ces deux régions en effet il
suffit d'avoir 33 % dans un contexte de
triangulaire au second tour pour diriger
l'une et l'autre de ces régions d'autres
conquêtes locales éventuelles en
perspective qui confirment la volonté du
parti d'amplifier son maillage
territorial et si on est bien loin des
baronies locales qui existent dans
d'autres parties l'enracinement apparaît
nécessaire mais c'est aussi surtout de
professionnaliser l'appareil partisan du
Front national parce que au aujourd'hui
si vous voulez avoir des gens qui sont
des permanents dans le parti qui
travaillent pour pour le parti et cetera
contenu des budgets des partis
politiques français vous pouvez pas
payer beaucoup de permanent avec le
financement public de la vie électoral
donc par quoi ça passe la construction
d'un appareil partisan ça passe par les
postes d'élus et les collaborateurs qui
vont avec des élus locaux un enjeu
financier donc et surtout des relais une
vitrine pour la grande conquête du FN et
de sa présidente l'élection
présidentielle de
2017 voilà Guillaume Dodin est avec nous
bonsoir Guillaume notre confrère de la
FP spécialiste du Front national êes
vous-même oui oui oui bah ces questions
pourê a un nombre de spécialist du Front
national VO nous on lutte contre le
chômage he je peux vous dire qu'avec le
boulot qu'on a filé aux spécialistes de
l'extrême droite ou du Front national là
vous a il a des emplois il y a des
emplois qui sont remplis hein vous avez
publié ce matin la charte du FN pour des
alliances second tour donc vous reprenez
assez largement votre programme et vous
proposez à des élus dans les
départements de la signer en échange des
voix du FN pour la la présidence des
départements est-ce que ça peut marcher
dans dans quel département ça dans le
gare dans le voclus dans c'estàd c'est
proposé évidemment dans des départements
où il y a pas de majorité et et où les
l'apport des voix des élus Front
national peut faire basculer la majorité
d'un côté ou de l'autre mais nous
faisons cela sans contreparti les choses
soit clair nous ne sommes pas là dans
les manœuvres d'appareil tu me donnes
une vice-présidence et je vote pour toi
nous sommes là pour faire respecter la
volonté de nos électeurs nos lecteurs
ils ont voté pour nous pour nous
défendions un programme nous disons à
ceux qui éventuellement seraient
intéressés par un soutien nous voulons
bien vous soutenir mais la contrepartie
c'est pas des postes ni des places c'est
que vous mettiez en œuvre l'engagement
de ne pas augmenter les impôts
l'engagement de lutter contre le
communautarisme l'engagement d'interdire
le voile dans les crèches et cetera et
cet mais Nicolas Sarkozi a déjà prévenu
que toute alliance avec le FN vaudrait
exclusion donc ça paraît assez é très
bien ben alors donc donc dans le gare
euh l'UMP par exemple va offrir le
département à la gauche vous pensez
qu'il aurait été normal que l'UMP
gouverne avec le F mais non mais dans
ces cas-là il faut pas dire partout sur
tous les plateaux oui le FNPS et voter
franç c'est voter PS non là pour le coup
voter UMP c'est voter PS mais tant mieux
ça ça moi tout ce qui contribue si vous
voulez à clarifier la réalité de ce que
qu l'UMPS va plutôt dans le bon sens
parce que je sais qu'il y a encore des
électeurs qui pensent que l'UMP fait et
défend un projet différent de celui du
Parti socialiste tout événement qui
vient leur expliquer la réalité à savoir
que non il mèneent exactement le même
programme et qu'après tout que ce soit
les uns ou les autres ça les dérange pas
trop mais dans les départements il vous
paraîtrait plus normal que les élus FN
gouvernent avec des élus de droite non
mais moi si si si les socialistes
viennent me dire que il refuse de
d'augmenter les impôts qui refuse le
communautarisme qui refuse le voileer
dans dans la crèche qui vont lutter pour
défendre les services publics de
proximité et cetera et cetera et ben
écoutez nous réfléchirons à leur
propositions le tout c'est qu'il
s'engage encore une fois sur les
éléments essentiel de notre projet
d'accord vous vous réunissez au premier
tour des départemental 25 % des voix
c'est le meilleur score de l'histoire du
FN vous êtes en tête dans 43
départements et au final vous avez 1,5 %
des élus vous remportez 1,5 % des
cantons c'est la démocratie française
mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu un
échec justement la la manière dont le
Front national se positionne dans la vie
politique française ah bon ça c'est un
échec donc en fait on a on a gagné ,5 %
des des des élus au final est-ce que
c'est pas un peu un échec c'est l'échec
de la démocratie c'est l'échec de la
démocratie qui fait que 25 % des
électeurs français ne sont pas
représentés dans des proportions qui
soient dignes euh à défaut d'être
égalitaire si vous voulez c'est un vrai
problème c'est un vrai souci ça fait des
décennies que ça dure et et c'est ce qui
contribue à créer ce gouffre entre le le
peuple français et ses représentants
tout simplement parce que les
représentant n'en sont pas vous le dites
vous-même ça fait des décennies que ça
dure donc à un moment donné est-ce que
le la stratégie du FN ne devrait pas
être de faire des alliance pour pouvoir
plutôt que d'avoir des en plus d'avoir
des bons scores en plus gouverner et
donc accéder à des positions de pouvoir
non mais d'abord monsieur pardon nous
avons quand même gagné des villes bon
dans ces villes d'ailleurs les résultats
ont été un véritable plébiscite bon
puisque les dans les les premiers tours
des élections départementales les scores
et même dans les 2è d'ailleurs dans le
2è les scorses qui ont été effectués
dans les villes Front national démontre
que la population euh euh est
extrêmement satisfaite de la gestion des
villes donc nous avons gagné des villes
bon euh nous avons gagné des cantons
nous en avons euh nous avons 62 élus
nous en nous en avions un bon on est
passé de 1 à 62 c'est quand même 62 sur
4100 c'est pas ah oui 62 sur 4100 je
suis bien d'accord avec vous et je vous
en jooins d'ailleurs peut-être à
regarder les résultats dans certains
départements euh le Front national fait
40 % parfois 15 points devant ses
adversaires il a zéro élus et les autres
en ont 12 ou 14 quanton alors c'est
profondément scandale problème du Front
national mais écoutez moi je vais pas me
vendre pour un plat de
lentillle je ne vais sûrement pas
mal'allier avec des gens qui mènne une
politique radicalement différente de
celle que je veux voir mener à ce
moment-là je ne sers à rien je veux dire
il y a toute une série de de gens à
l'UMP au PS qui passent leur vie à
appeler à voter les uns pour les autres
à se désister les uns pour les autres
c'est déjà il y a déjà un parti unique
de ce côtél bon moi je suis là pour
proposer une alterna et vous avez
d'autres élections qui s'annoncent avec
un scrutin un mode de scrutin qui vous
est plus favorable les régionales vous
avez parlé de pouvoir gagner dans quatre
ou 5 régions donc il y a le nordp de Cal
Picardie où là vous allez peut-être vous
avez fait des très bons scores je crois
que c'est de l'ordre de 34 % il y a la
PACA vous avez fait 33 % donc ça va être
c'est les départements les plus
accessibles vous vous avez fait les
calculs oui bah si vous voulez le le
mode de scrutin des régionales est un
mode de scrutin radicalement différent
de celui des départementales c'est celui
qui arrive en tête au second tour qui
gagne la région voilà c'est aussi simple
que cela donc nous allons probablement
évidemment nous retrouver en
triangulaire donc il y a pas 50
possibilités pour l'UMPS soit il se
retire l'un se retire au bénéfice de
l'autre et il disparaît totalement de la
région pendant 6 ans soit il fusionne
les listes PS hein c'est ce que Monsieur
leer de l'UMP a proposé d'ors et déjà
dans le Nord il a proposé de présenter
une liste commune UMPS et il dit
d'ailleurs que Madame auri serait
d'accord bon donc vous voyez que tout va
pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes soit ils appellent un est éliminé
et et et ils appellent à à voter les ou
soit ils se maintiennent voilà que trois
possibilités nous pouvons gagner bien
sûr nous pouvons gagner et parce que
nous sommes dans beaucoup de
départements les plus forts mais vous
avez été jusqu'à dire que même dans Midi
pirané langd Rousillon la victoire était
ACC parce qu'il faut arriver en tête or
nous sommes arrivés en tête le bloc de
gauche on est d'accord que ils vont pas
forcément s'unir parfaitement mais le
bloc de gauche par exemple dans cette
région fait presque 20 points de plus
que le FN et bien nous verrons nous
verrons et pour les départementales vous
ne faisiez aucun pronostic là-dessus on
est d'accord vous en faites pour les
régionales comment expliquez-vous celaou
ben parce que précisément je pense que
le mode de scrutin des départementals
est un mode de scrutin cééra puisqu'il
prive 25 % des électeurs français d'une
représentation légitime et que je sais
parfaitement qu'au dernier moment l'UMP
et le PS se mettent ensemble appelle à
voter les uns pour les autres se désiste
au bénéfice des uns ou au bénéfice des
autres et que donc il est imprévisible
il est très difficile de prévoir si vous
voulez le nombre de cantons qui peuvent
être gagnés ce qui est prévisible c'est
que l'UMPS est de plus en plus fusionné
entre eux et que bah après tout il
ferait bien de faire un parti unique et
puis comme ça au moins ce serait et dire
que des régions sont gagnables vous
pensez que ça mobilise particulièrement
vos électeurs ça les incite à aller non
mais je dis la vérité voilà je dis la
réalité de ce qui est ces régions sont
gagnables si je regarde les élections
européennes et si je regarde les
élections départementales étant entendu
que les réflexes de vote sont à mon avis
plus proches des européennes dans des
régionales que des départementales parce
qu'il y a beaucoup moins quand même de
de de d'aspects local dans des
régionales surtout dans des grandes
régions fusionné oui nous pouvons gagner
un certain nombre de région vous
n'arrêtez pas de parler de l'UMPS mais
Nicolas Sarkozi a été très ferme sur la
doctrine du Nini vous une B entrée non
non ah B al bon ben alors il faut qu'il
quitte la tête de l'UMP parce que
personne ne l'a écouté parce que dans la
Drome parce que dans le N pas decalais
parce que en dans la Meuse parce qu'en
Moselle parce que à nî euh tous les UMP
ont appelé à voter PS et ils se sont
même désistés pour permettre l'élection
du de de de de socialistes et même
parfois de communistes comme ça a été le
cas à perpignon les UMP appelant à voter
communistes alors arrêtons le cinéma je
comprend pas bien dans une interview à
paraarître à à causeur vous dites que
l'UMPS n'existe pas pour la
présidentielle alors ça existe à
certaines élections et à d'autres non
parce que la présidentielle est une
élection tout à fait particulière où les
étiquettes des partis politiques ne
rentrent pas en ligne de compte ou c'est
la personnalité des candidats eu qui est
importante c'est la rencontre entre un
homme ou une femme et le peuple
directement et donc je pense que euh euh
d'ailleurs vous imaginez bien on peut se
l'imaginer entre nous que des reports de
voie euh par exemple du du Parti
socialiste ne seraient pas les mêmes sur
euh Nicolas Sarkozi ou sur euh àin Jupé
ils en jouent d'ailleurs l'un et l'autre
donc on voit bien que ce sont des ce ce
cette UMPS fonctionne évidemment moins
bien ça veut pas dire que le Parti
socialiste éjecté du second tour
n'appellerait pas à voter UMP et
viceversain c'est exactement
probablement ce qui se passera mais bien
sûr mais bien sûr parce qu'en fait ils
ne survivent qu'en s'entraînant François
Hollande appelant à voter Nicolas
Sarkozy sûr mais bien sûr parce que il
ne il n'existe qu' en centit dans l'un
l'autre en réalité si l'un disparaît
l'autre disparaît aussi euh Florian
Filippo avaiit raison de dire ce sont
les inséparables je veux dire quand l'un
meurt l'autre meurt aussi euh et donc
ces réflexes-là leur permettent de se
maintenir au pouvoir depuis des années
euh sans respecter la volonté du peuple
de l'un ou de l'autre lequel
préféreriez-vous avoir comme adversaire
du second tour si vous y parvenez mais
j'ai pas de préférence j'aurais pas je
vais vous dire j'aurais pas une ligne à
changer de mon argumentaire contre l'un
ou contre l'autre ils ont mené la même
politique serait peut-être un moins
grand danger ils ont mené la même
politique moi je fais de la politique
ils ont mis les mêmes m chiffre de
l'immigration les mêmes délires de du
laxisme en matière judiciaire le le le
le même la même politique économique
plus dangereux que vous que pour vous ça
a l'air ça a l'air plus simple en
général pour le Front national face à un
candidat de gauche par exemplee façon
non mais de toute façon on parle de rien
là on parle pour ne rien dire c'est pas
nous qui décidons c'est le peuple
français qui décide donc laissons la
primaire UMPS se dérouler la primaire de
la primaire UMPS sortira le candidat de
l'UMPS le candidat du système qui
arrivera au second
tourour vous êtes SR d'être au second
tour s on n'est jamais sûr de rien je
veux dire je peux sortir demain de de
votre studio il peut m'arriver n'importe
quoi écoutez même pendant l'émission il
reste encore 20 minutes bon en tout cas
vous l'affirmer votre objectif c'est
l'Élysée et pour parvenir à l'Élysée
faut 50 % plus une voix quelle est la
stratégie que vous allez développer pour
ça sachant que toutes les élections le
montrent vous progressez mais au deème
tour scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
c'est quand même compliqué toujours pour
le Front national de c'est compliqu B
enfin c'est compliqué mais enfin il y y
a des il y a des augmentations
spectaculaires entre les deux tours
quand même bien sûr mais là il y a des
augmentations depuis 2012 personne le
conteste mais euh départemental 1100
second tour 30 30 élections donc il y a
encore ça se généralise au niveau de la
France d'accord 30 élection mais vous
avez vous-même fait le calcul euh plus
de 90 canton euh ou 99 je crois qu'Anton
qui était entre 45 et 50 dont 22 qui
était entre 48 et 50 bon donc donc voilà
non mais ça ça je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de de vouloir absolument
intégrer des mathématiques dans la
poliétique la poliétique c'est autre
chose que des mathématiques voilà c'est
c'est c'est un lien ex et ben man dit la
même chose car qu'il a conservé le lien
avec les Français c'est un lien charnel
avec non Emmanuel Vals il fait une
politique déplorable et les Français
sont conscients que ce soit lui ou un
autre ce sera la même politique
déplorable car ils ont compris
précisément que ça n'est pas le
gouvernement qui décide que c'est Madame
Merkel qui décide voilà voilà ce qu'ils
ont compris les Français et donc vous
c'est un lien charnel entre le
candidat celui qui celui qui aspire à
représenter le peuple français et le
peuple français voilà et donc il n'y a
pas de logique mathématique qui rentre
en ligne de compte d'autant que les
dangers qui pèsent sur notre pays sont
de plus en plus importants et ils vont
continuer à
s'aggraver soit économique et sociaux du
fait de la politique imposée par l'Union
européenne soit sur le plan de
l'immigration car ce sujet est évacué et
volontairement sembleil accuer du débat
et pourtant il est essentiel ce sont des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
cherchent aujourd'hui à rejoindre
l'Union européenne qui est une véritable
passoire la déstabilisation de la
Tunisie qui est la conséquence des
erreurs politiques que Nicolas Sarkozi a
commis en Libye tout cela évidemment va
continuer à faire peser sur le pays un
poids qui va devenir au fur et à mesure
insupportable dernière information sur
le 3è tour départemental Dans le vaucl
la gauche ne va pas présenter de
candidat à l'exécutif ça vous donne ça
vous donnera pas l'occasion de voter
pour la gauche alors oh c'est
merveilleux bah voilà tiens l'UMPS
regardez comme ils sont beaux regardez
pour permettre l'élection de l'UMP le
parti socialiste ne va pas présenter de
candidat il y aura peut-être une
contrepartie dans un autre département
non qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je sais
pas mais peut-être ce que j'en pense
c'est que peut-être vous auriez pu vous
créer un peu du trouble supplémentaire
en votant pour le candidat socialiste
par exemple nous avons un candidat nous
nous avons un candidat nous présentons
un candidat
à la à la présidence du du département
mais j'attends de voir quelle sera la
contrepartie de ce retrait du Parti
socialiste au bénéfice de l'UMP il y a
de nombreux pays de nombreux systèmes
politiques où les partis font entre des
alliances c'est pas le le diable que de
faire des alliances entre partis
politiqu entre partis qui sont
adversaire bah ils peuvent être
adversaires et se retrouver sur
certaines politiques ah oui non mais là
là ils se retrouvent avant l'élection là
quand même moi des adversaires qui se
retrouvent ensemble avant
l'élection non mais avant l'élection il
se retrouve voilà l'UMPS il se retrouve
avant l'élection donc il a quand même
pas beaucoup de système politique où les
adversaires se retrouvent avant
l'élection sauf en France pour une
raison simple c'est qu'en réalité en
réalité cette opposition monsieur Dodin
est factice voilà elle est là pour
amuser la galerie mais il n'y a plus de
différence entre la gauche et la droite
depuis bien longtemps et vous changeriez
les étiquettes des des gens qui ont été
élus vous n'y veriez que du feu merci
Guillaume perinna de Public Sénat arrive
maintenant Marine Le Pen nous allons
évoquer votre programme donc différent
totalement différent de vos adversaires
l'UMP et le PS avec vos solutions
miracles qui nous mènerit selon ne soyez
pas méprisant soyez pas méprisant
solution miracle il y a pas de miracle
vos solutions j'allais dire j'allais
faire jeis faire un mot des solutions
miracle qui
s'apparent un cauchemar pour certains
économistes et vos adversaires alors
êtes-vous sûr d'abord d'avoir choisit le
bon positionnement politique d'ailleurs
la question est relancée ave on choisit
un positionnement politique on défend
pas la question est relancée on va le
voir vous fréquentez trop souventps vous
la question est relancée après le second
tour départemental vous allez voir on va
en parler avec per dans un instant
d'abord la présentation de vos mesures
ah j' avectience la caricature avec
Sandra ckera et vous allez voir il y a
des personnes vos conseillers économique
du FN qui parlent dans le sujet d'accord
Marine Le Pen a un objectif le pouvoir
et pour l'atteindre elle met en avant
depuis 2012 l'économie et le social pour
tenter de gagner en crédibilité au cœur
de son programme la sortie de l'euro le
conseiller économique de Marine Le Pen
l'assure d'évaluer notre monnaie
permettra de retrouver la compétitivité
si on baisse de 25 % notre monnaie vis
de l'Allemagne immédiatement toutes les
Peugeot et Renault vont se vendre comme
des petits P en Europe puisquelles
seront 25 % moins cher comparativement
que Volkswagen pour beaucoup d'experts
Marine Le Pen promet la lune passer au
nouveau franc ne ferait qu'ajouter des
difficultés à une économie française
déjà morose une situation explosive au
niveau de l'endettement une méfiance
très importante à l'égard de la dette
française une augmentation des taux
d'intérêt internationaux avec lesquels
on peut refinancer notre dette donc là
effectivement ce sont des engagements
qui sont très très lourd et intenable
autre mesure économique du Front
national augmenter les salaires un coup
de pouce de 200 € net à tous les
salariés touchant moins de 1500 € c'est
pas qu'on va donner on va augmenter le
SMIC c'est qu'il va augmenter parce
qu'on va baisser les cotisations payées
par les salariés les cotisations
salariales alors ça coûte quelques
milliards mais ça sera compensé par
justement une taxe de 3 % sur les
produits importés cet économiste dénonce
une mesure démagogique qui coûterait 20
milliards d'euros et plomberait la
compétitivité des entreprises je crois
qu'il y a une forme de paradoxe d'un
côté de dire je veux défendre le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés j'augmente le
salaire et au même moment je les taxe en
dévaluant et en mettant en place des
droits de doine mais je crois que le
programme du du Front national est
rempli en réalité de contradictions des
contradictions qui pourraient nuire à la
crédibilité du programme et détourné du
FN une partie de son électorat comme les
artisans et les petits entrepreneurs
effrayés par un protectionnisme à
outrance voilà pine Tarna est avec nous
bonsoir pine alors nous allonsondir sur
ce sujet qui a fait bouillir Marine Le
Pen pendant sa diffusion écoutez est-ce
que Marine Le Pen votre programme
économique ne déroute pas des électeurs
qui doute de sa faisabilité non ce qui
déroute c'est les mensonges que leur
déverse ces pseudo experts qui sont en
réalité des fumistes je vous le dis
gentiment mais clairement voilà
quelqu'un qui vient dire que la
proposition que nous faisons de faire
prendre en charge par l'État 200 € de la
part salariale des cotisations sociales
plomberait la compétitivité des
entreprises et par quel bout parce que
ça plombe leur compte hein
supplémentaire un salair pris par l'État
pris par l'État
oui c'est ça donc ça coûte 20 milliards
et les 20 milliards ils sont financés
par une contribution sociale à
l'importation avoir peur si vous voulez
de se retrouver avec des salaires trop
élevés est-ce que l'État va pouvoir
pendant x
Ann avoir 200 € de plus qu'elles nauront
pas payé et qui comm si l'État n'a pas
les moyens si vous voulez d'offrir ces
200 € net par
mois excuse-moi on va sarrêter là tout
suite de quoi vous me parlez là l'état
pas les moyens de quoi je vous dis que
cette mesure est financée d'accordn
financé par une tous les ans elle est
financée par une contribution sociale à
l'importation de 3 % voyez je vais vous
dire je vais commencer par dénoncer de
la manière la plus ferme et la plus
officielle la manière dont nous sommes
traités sur les plateaux de télévision
et par ce genre d'expert on raconte
n'importe quoi voilà n'importe quoi au
français on caricature le programme du
Front national on ne sait même pas de
quoi on parle car on l'a en général même
pas lu ce monsieur-là il l'a même pas lu
croit qu'on va augmenter de 200 € le
SMIC ce qui évidemment est une mauvaise
mesure car ça entraînerait une prise en
charge par les entreprises qui n'en
peuvent plus de d'une charge qui serait
insupportable pour elle voyez le le le
la la la mauvaise foi alors c'est où de
la mauaise FO de
l'incompétence
possibilit il met en doute le
financement il met en doute le
financement l'allement fin venez de me
dire vous venez de me dire c'est financé
pour combien de temps donc vous n'avez
pas lu vous vous n'avez pas lu que nous
voulons mettre en place une contribution
sociale à l'importation de 3 % sur les
produits importés qui donc évidemment
arrivve tous les ans parce que
figurez-vous qu' a les produits importés
qui arrivent tous les an sur le pouvoir
d'achat du coup de manière dériso non
mais ça augmente les prix ça c'est de
manière dérisoire monsieur par rapport
par rapport aux 200 € que vont pouvoir
obtenir les salaires les plus ferbles de
manière dérisoire voilà bon toujours
est-il qu'il y a peut-être un électorat
de droite qui est un petit peu dérouté
par votre programme économique et qui ne
vous suit pas notamment sur la partie
très étatiste interventionniste
des nationalisation par
exemple non mais madame c'est pareil bon
là aussi on est dans la caricature la
plus total on nous explique Marine Le
Pen et comme Mélenchon veut nationaliser
tout évidemment ça non mais c'est ce que
dit par exemple monsieur gataz qui est
censé au li aussi un grand ponte un
grand patron il raconte n'importe quoi
il il a il il s'inquiète du coup d'une
nationalisation partielle des
B n'importe quoi d'ailleurs je remarque
que je lui ai lancé la proposition d'un
débat mais on préfère
caricaturerogram voilà dans challenge
plutôt que de venir débattre avec Marine
Le Pen on pourrait éventuellement être
gêné être gêné d'être obligé de montrer
soit qu'on maîtrise pas ce dont on parle
soit qu'on ne connaît absolument pas le
programme du Front national la
nationalisation temporaire des des
banques elle ne doit s'effectuer que si
les banques sont en très grave
difficultés mais dites-moi ça n'est pas
ce qu'a fait la Grande-Bretagne est-ce
que la grande Bretagne est considéré
comme un pays d'extrême gauche je ne le
crois
pasb des banques mais n'a pas
nationalisé bien sûr que si mais bien
sûr que si Madame bien sûr que si elle a
nationalisé les banques voilà et et et
pourtant c'est un pays libéral mais à un
moment donné quand on voit que des
banques sont en train de tomber mieux
vaut les nationaliser de manière
temporaire pour préserver évidemment
l'intérêt des déposants plutôt que de
voir la situation échapper au contrôle
de l'État stratège l'état stratège c'est
du de Gaul je veux dire faut pas moi je
veux bien que ça